okay I think it's fair to say that 2020
fever has sort of hit a lot of the David
Pakman show audience because this
morning I was on the David Pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash read
it where we have moderators and
respectful political conversation
happening with more than 7,000 of our
viewers and listeners and I spotted an
interesting thread about 2020 we've been
talking about what about Bernie for 2020
and user are fishbein 91 says if you
like Bernie Sanders also consider
senator sherrod Brown for 2020 saying
that she already talked about why she
thinks sherrod Brown would be a
phenomenal 2020 candidate for the
Democrats that the good news is that
sherrod Brown is actually considering it
and this user outlines sherrod Browns
progressive voting record points out
that he might have more appeal in the
Midwest than Bernie Sanders I actually
think that this is very interesting and
it's not interesting for any reasons of
a sort of ageism
I know that people have sometimes said
that when I talk about running an old
white guy against an old white guy that
there's something of a sort of identity
argument being made and and that's
really not what it is but I actually do
find sherrod Brown interesting as a
candidate Pat now I'm not as closely
aligned with him politically I took my
political alignment test last week I'm
mostly aligned most closely with Bernie
and with Elizabeth Warren
but sherrod Brown is an interesting name
to throw in here yeah I want to reserve
my judgments until all the candidates
have announced but I I take it that if
Bernie Sanders runs for president again
I'm going to support him now the real
question is if Bernie decides not to run
who we gonna back is gonna be Elizabeth
Warren is it gonna be sherrod Brown
that's a totally open question or even
Joe Manchin maybe the progressive base
will align behind the most conservative
Democratic senator in the country I
think not and that would be a disaster
I'm obviously kidding that would be the
exact wrong direction for Democrats to
go also from the David Pakman show
subreddit this morning a discussion
about what the democratic
platform should be and this is relevant
in two ways what should the Democratic
platform be for 2020 but also it relates
to a question we're gonna answer on the
Friday show about what should be the
Democratic priorities when they take
over the house and user free-range grape
says that he would like to see
single-payer health care or at least
limiting insurance company overhead to
5% or so enacted switching to the metric
system like the rest of the world yeah I
just don't know that you're gonna win
too many votes with that one I agree a
hundred and ten percent that we should
switch to the metric system I think that
there are significant financial costs to
switching in the short term I just don't
think the metric system is a voting
issue Pat probably not I don't think
we're gonna win back any voters who were
disenfranchised by Hillary Clinton the
states like you know Michigan and
Pennsylvania and Wisconsin they're not
gonna vote based on the metric system no
no I don't think so either high-speed
rail transportation I think that that's
great although in a lot of parts of the
country it's sort of a non-starter with
our elected officials renewable and
clean energy absolutely publicly funded
elections absolutely free Community
College and affordable public
universities allow student loans to be
forgiven under bankruptcy filing all
very very important and answering the
question how will we pay for all those
things answer according to free-range
grape the same way we pay for the
massive military budget yeah I think
that this is actually putting aside
these specific issues it would be really
great for Democrats and the left in
general to have a more structured
response to how are we going to afford
that because there's a few different
ways that you can start answering that
one is saying well it's money we're
already spending that we can just
reallocate sometimes the answer is
slightly higher taxes on the rich the
truth may be a combination of these
things but I do think the left has to
get better at answering that question
because it actually is an obvious
question that the middle and the right
is going to ask and we need to be united
on what the answer is lastly from the
david pakman show subreddit this morning
jordan peterson seems to have lied about
serving
a United Nations Committee on climate
change yeah you know what a bunch of
people emailed me about this story Pat
and said you've got to cover this and I
looked into it it does indeed seem that
Jordan Peterson at one point claimed to
have actually served on a UN committee
about climate change
it seems the truth is that he once in
some way advised someone who served on
such a committee I don't even care like
the you know at this point I I feel like
for the majority of what we do on the
show Jordan Peterson is an interesting
component of this movement known as the
intellectual dark web but the specifics
of when Peterson lied or tell the truth
but told the truth I feel like are not
particularly relevant to our sort of
narrative and discourse is that because
in this postmodern world what's true and
what's not true isn't discernible
anymore and it's all just subjective now
yeah what is truth anyway right like
what does it even really mean to say
Jordan Peterson lied do we even know
what a lie is do words have any meaning
at this point the answer is no if you're
participating in the toxic
post-modernism of the left yes if you
are trying to argue with so-called sjw's
or whatever anyway join the discussion
david pakman.com slash re d di t a lot
of really good conversations happening
there with more than 7,000 of our
viewers and listeners one of today's
sponsors is privacy comm slash Pakman
this is a free service that I've
actually been using myself for a while
now and I love it you just take a few
seconds to link your debit card or bank
account to privacy coms mobile app or
browser extension for Firefox and Chrome
and what that does is allow you to
instantly create virtual credit cards
that are linked to your bank account so
that you're not actually putting your
real debit card number on the Internet
and you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online and with
one click of a button you have the
ability to create multiple virtual cards
delete cards freeze and unfreeze cards
you can put a limit on a
so a company won't be able to charge you
more than you actually want them to and
it protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below